let's talk for a few minutes about Noam
Chomsky because you talk about him a bit
in the book it's not a tremendous amount
but you but I have a friend who's on
what I consider in this regressive group
and a lot of times we'll be debating
back and forth about this stuff and I'll
be giving him as much historical
knowledge as I have and as much factual
knowledge as I have and then he'll sort
of always end everything by saying well
I don't really know about that but I
read some Chomsky and I'm just kind of
giving it back to you and I think you
sort of hit on that also in the book
that there there's just this belief in
this guy that maybe isn't fully
warranted or he's been he's been very
good at waving off the things that don't
quite agree with his worldview yeah it's
it's interesting for two reasons I mean
born you know without he's an old guy
and I don't come up yeah yes shutting
down by me he's adopted some pretty
disgraceful positions denying the mastic
is above Bosnian Muslims and going along
with people who it's 1990s and going a
long time and never admitting is wrong
and building this very in trance keys
writing it it's very poor writing self
stands of English but it builds this
very dense web and like your friend
wants your annual like a fly shorting
the web is very hard to get out so
that's but that's that's kind of missing
you say fiscally in America you feel
tied I know what this thing is but I
don't know yeah you say look this man
this is this is all from the point of
view it's sort of made up and actually
you think about what he's doing it's
quite disgraceful but here's why I for
Chomsky was worth devoting Championships
is this what kind of you are young
radical an American campus and you get
your Chomsky you read all these books
and you think well what kind of society
are you aiming for there is no social
vision there's nothing that the
progressives and socialists who run for
American history from the 1880s would
recognize they'll just say what's this
all just saying America's [ __ ]
you get me marecus [ __ ] America probably
never have happened the pilgrim files we
probably have turned around a Plymouth
Rock and gone back to England yeah the
whole thing is this a stir everything it
does it's writing it's a lie and you
think that's a ridiculous world fish
funnily enough here's the thing it's
really easy to buy into it yeah because
you don't have to commit to anything you
know gives you the regressive left and
so I really like that phrase well let's
take the regressives where yeah Big Sean
skin left the post-socialist left on the
one hand it has very very little to say
positive on your hand that's that's kind
of easy frivolous sign up to you just
have to think that Washington is a pile
of [ __ ] well we know I mean washing GC
is a pile of [ __ ] well that's sure as
you get up yeah doctor that the State
Department doesn't know what it's doing
yeah fine the CIA is wicked and so
instead of having a left wing you had to
make really positive commitments for you
know 40 years ago I can count on your
program and said I'm a socialist right
I'm a socialist and your audience might
say oh I need Karen Jesus socialist that
sounds good we'll go on give me just and
I said I want massively high tech six or
I want to nationalize this and that and
people who would have been agree we said
well back off and say hell I don't want
anything to do this yeah this guy is
threatening my living standards now you
just have to say that everything you
reads a lie your governments evil and
this is it and so suddenly that's
actually because they are making so few
positive policy commits as Chomsky does
it's suddenly very easy to go along with
him you know I go to the homes of people
here in London which is the very
expensive city I go into the richest
people I know and their books by Noam
Chomsky on the on the pop yeah on the on
their shelves and that's because
suddenly enough for all suppose
radicalism that kind of left and without
a positive program with just the
critique is no threat to them it's no
threat to the world is no threat to a
powerful is no threat to the bankers on
Wall Street you know it's something lots
of people when they're quite justifiably
often pissed off the government
or because you know that they they've
got a conspiracy theory mind or because
they will look friendly everyone can
sign up to that
genuine left-wing program is hard again
you and left-wing program makes friends
and enemies but this kind of pseudo
leftist regressive left it's terribly
easy even too easy I think for any
successful political movement you know
it's interesting because I was really
embedded in it for a couple years and I
guess I hadn't pieced this all together
what you're talking about but right now
but part of my frustration was that we
never talked about solutions we always
could talk about problems right it was
always you know the American industrial
complex and and bombing and race and
whatever but there were never solutions
so that that does get to what you're
saying that it's sort of you could pick
as soon as you offer solution you're
going to piss some people off yeah
because it's pollution meat and you have
to make a commitment and as soon as you
make a commitment the people can say oh
look days Ruben believes in this once is
wrong it is very easy to just say it's
all conspiracy it's all stick yeah that
way you don't expose yourself you're not
making you're not making a postive
program and sticking your neck out there
I where you see who shoots you down
so speaking of conspiracy theories one
of the through lines throughout the book
and then you do devote a chapter to it
in completion is that in all of these
movements somehow blaming the Jews
always it always comes around to blaming
the Jews now the language is changed now
it's blaming Zionists you're blamed
beginning right David you know says to
usually most honest right now it's right
it's not it's not politically correct to
say Jews so you just say Zionists or you
say Israel or whatever it is but you
really did lay out an interesting piece
in almost every example throughout time
that they were always but on both sides
the capitalists would say the Jews are
socialists the socialists would say Jews
are capitalists and every other which
way what what do you think that is about
I think you probably just explained it
with this conspiratorial thing and the
other right yeah well look he's wrong if
you genuinely think your State
Department your CIA
you're president for all all their many
many Falls and I'm sure their lesion and
but if you genuinely think that they for
instance secretly blew out the twin
towers and then they al-qaeda take the
plane they invented a way to go into war
and rock a bomber is you've lice the
writers much the left you know a barber
isn't a real American he's a secret
Muslim from Kenya you know if you can
you believe it all that you have to
believe in extraordinary view of the
world where a handful of people can fool
the entire populations the sheeple well
once you thinking a lot who are those
handful of people historically you know
well you start down that road you end up
in the Goodes what I found shocking
being called cowling is a genus yeah and
I think some of you know your liberal
American Jews will find it shocking
because I say way if I'd had use ahead
of you when it comes in hits in is this
I help
I never expect you to find out two
senators longer perhaps I was being
naive and but it is quite extraordinary
the extent of it and it's quite
extraordinary how its tolerated now it
isn't cool down now so do you think some
of that when I hear people say that and
first real quick we should mention so
you just mention your last name Cohen
you're actually not Jewish though you
know who you know might not my family
abandon their religion for rigid Marxist
so you know I'm a I'm I'm from an ex
Tommy his family of about 1903 Jews
wouldn't have been stupid but yeah yeah
call Cohen Dave it's not yeah right
circle people finger accused and also
you're curious but here's the problem if
you look at Auntie services
anti-semitism has virtually nothing to
do with you
anti-semitism became in the late
nineteenth century the early 20th
century and the czars and Nazis it was a
way of fighting progress it was a way of
saying look you democracy human
rights women's rights yeah all these you
shouldn't believe in them it they're all
plagues they're all fraud says a they're
all behind them is a pipe master pulling
the strings in that puppet master with
the cute
so yeah you would have thought there's a
left that believes in democracy and
human rights will be for its own sake as
much as anything else only on alert the
whole time for the dangers of entities
journalism but actually you know going
back to transcode believes the box see
they believe human rights is all they
believe it's all lie so that's one
reason why they end up there or not
Trump's himself but that's why I'm using
people are people end up there and they
don't understand what goes with it they
don't look at organizations like
Hezbollah or Iran or and say homeless
ech okay they're anti-semitic but that's
just because of Israel and then they go
several home take a look at where they
she'd women look at where they treat
homosexuals look at the way that they
dismiss human rights the way this miss
democracy in girls and anti-semitism
actually goes along with that and once
you accept anti-semitism you have to not
just throw out anti-racist but you have
to wrap all your progressive principles
because historically anti-semitism has
always been used by ultra yatra
movements who again
the left should be against right so this
I always say when it comes to this and I
was just in Israel last week and at the
top of the show when I when I did my my
piece I was saying how I saw coexistence
there I was in Jerusalem you know I ate
falafel in the Arab quarter I saw
Israeli policemen helping Muslim women
move a box I saw ultra-orthodox Jews
well I mean that doesn't happen anywhere
in the Mideast
except for Israel and of course not to
say everything's perfect there and
there's all sorts of political problems
and religious problems and all that but
that does but the only place that is any
progressive values in the Middle East is
Israel and they well yeah yeah yeah but
I mean look
you shouldn't engage in about what about
three Big Jim and it's a lot of wasp al
to invest there's quite a lot what about
three on the right you know you say
someone says well as problems on the
West Bank there's problems in Gaza you
say what about Syria it's actually is
quite a good what now right but yeah
then we said tell us about when you
think about it and but you know you
shouldn't say that doesn't mean the
Palestinians should have their own
statements as you know horrendous
problems with Israeli right and you
shouldn't romanticise Israel yeah at all
and but but yeah but here's the thing is
the problem the problem is is this is
one of the great reasons for I would say
the liberal liberal difficulty in
understanding radical Islam is there's
very good liberal impulses assumes the
world is rational you know that assumes
that if there is this terrible
terroristic movement that will blur the
twin towers that would we knew if they
had chemical weapons or nuclear weapons
if used against civilians they would
then must be a huge cause for it you
know there must be some rational
explanation that we can satisfy that we
can procreate these evil gods and they
can't just be that angry again it's
tough it's not partly our fault
yeah I saw I saw a lot of that actually
right after the Paris attacks because I
saw immediately my friends on the Left
saying American foreign policy American
foreign policy even though two days
later you know Boko Haram killed 140
people and obviously that has nothing to
do with another policy but but there's
this rationalization even though at the
same time the people who did the Paris
attacks were saying this is for
religious purposes yeah but your friends
are left your souls go into history of
narcissism with history of communism yes
there are rational reasons that you can
blame you know you could say if if yeah
bombs go off like Charlie Hebdo
office in Paris your friends Lester oh
it's their fault they fluent in cartoons
of Muhammad yeah people are slaughtered
at at the very supermarket in Paris the
hydrocal a super mob how is their fault
because of Israel because Israel is
occupying the West Bank it's okay you
kill the satirist that's okay you kill
the Jews that's okay people are
slaughtered at a football stadium start
the parents people are slaughtered our
rock concert people are sort of the
Cambodian restaurant on the Parisian
Boulevard
well that's killing as their fault
because well we're not quite sure
American foreign policy maybe friends
foreign policy now these are sort of
rational explanations and there's a bit
of truth in them
the problem is every step you take seems
rational and liberal but every step you
take takes you away from rationality and
liberalism and you end up like the very
murderers you're trying to explain
because you accept the whole ideology
but you don't understand it you don't
understand that there are not people who
are sitting there saying well we've got
a rational grievance like someone's
about to file a claim it's a County
Court they have a utopian totalitarian
ideology you know and having lived
through the 20th century or a last bit
of the 20th century 20th century when
you choking ideology still millions of
millions of people we still don't
understand that someone like Islamic
state says we think we can create heaven
on earth we think we can create a
caliphate that will govern the whole
earth and this will be paradox and to do
that what what's it matter with 1
million 2 million 10 million people are
killed they don't they think they're
explained they don't understand anything
yeah so that actually is the ultimate
irony because on one hand you're saying
well look if we took everything if we
did whatever it is they want us to do
right we took all our troops out of here
we stopped bombing here whatever then
suddenly they they'd like us more but
that's not what they're saying so it
really is it's it's the most ironic whoa
what they want you to do Davis become
them yes to anybody if you look and so
here you go I mean your friends in
California I'm probably yeah I met
though I'm sure they're lovely people so
so the video dark um but you know I'm
sure they they think themselves as
anti-sexist anti-racist I actually have
a phobic I'm sure they're fine on trans
issues you know I bet some of them don't
even me eat meat but they will then
through thinking they're being logical
end up defending the most sexist racist
homophobic a liberal movements on earth
and do so in a it's not a point made by
me as point made by a very brilliant
French philosopher do so in a very
narcissistic way you know it's all our
fault we are the center of the world you
know if something terrible happens it
must be down to us not that people in
the rest the world have their own agency
not people in the rest welcome just as
wicked or stupid as we can they are
infants they are children who are goaded
by us it's all down to what we do we are
still here the narcissist the ego the
people the people who centrical yeah I
think when I had Douglas Marianne he
Illustrated a point he said look the
world could go to hell in a handbasket
and it'll have nothing to do with
America you know there's you just can't
it's just child its childlike thinking
all right so increase instead he treats
Muslim populations as children you know
if you infantile this is a yeah I mean
says he says look we're adults where we
are these white Western Europeans yeah
we can handle satire we can handle our
leaders and gods and bishops and clerics
not by God you can't do blessed Muslims
like toddlers here like vine little
delinquent children you said in the
cartoon they don't want they start
blowing the place up yeah
ironically that's what george w bush
called the soft bigotry of low
expectations which I keep crediting Bill
Maher with but apparently it was george
w bush which is well mind-blowing does
happen that is a very very good for face
and it's true and actually it's worse
than soft bigotry
it does keep people down because look
muslim men and women watching your
program and Kalla
for new doesn't really help them when
they're going out looking for a job or
looking to get on in life or want
increasing respect want to be creative
equals if liberals are saying oh well
you know very very funny people these
people you have to be very careful what
you say in France on one cartoon and
they'll blow the top my year here it
doesn't help them doesn't help them be
full citizens to be treated in a totally
different way from everyone